[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group you never
sign your signature exactly the same way
tonight on politics now election
officials tell us how they compare
signatures on ballots
and if the process they use rather when
they don't match
suzy lee is attacking me she's attacking
my family
on tv nonstop we dig into congressional
district three the race for that seat
where republican dan rodimer defends
himself against allegations he's
dangerous and violent
plus basically he's running on a record
of basically being pro-trump and he's
holding on to those coattails incumbent
congresswoman susie lee responds to
attacks
she's a puppet for speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
early voting for the general election is
officially underway
in nevada thank you for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler
so early voting started today it runs
until october
30th there are 48 in-person voting
locations
however the dates and the times for them
here in clark county vary so
check them out at eightnewsnow.com first
mail-in ballots are also out some have
already been returned
you can drop them off at the in-person
locations or
just put them in the mail here in clark
county more than 1.2
million ballots were sent out 516
thousand
democrats 357 thousand to registered
republicans
388 000 were sent to registered
nonpartisan or other parties
so far forty seven thousand ballots have
been returned about four percent
the breakdown you see on your screen
twenty seven thousand by democrats
nine thousand by republicans and ten
thousand by non-partisan voters
not a large amount but democrats are
taking a big
early lead we have been getting a lot of
questions from you
about election integrity president
donald trump has
questioned nevada's process and says it
might be stolen
the concern is about the mail-in ballots
and whether they could lead to
fraudulent votes
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
closer look at signature verification
each signature on each ballot in nevada
must be verified
the first step in that process is
running it through our mail ballot
processing system
registrar joe gloria says in clark
county each ballot is scanned
software determines whether the voter's
signature matches the signature on file
from
multiple sources like voter registration
or even a driver's license
if the machine rejects the ballot
election workers take a look
if two workers decide the signatures do
not match
they are advised to contact the voter we
must
statutorily contact that voter and give
them an opportunity to cure that ballot
gloria says a voter can respond through
the secretary of state's app where they
can sign an affidavit and provide their
nevada driver's license or
id or through the registrar they can
provide answers to three questions about
personal information so their ballot is
counted
for a ballot to be rejected in the first
place
there has to be significant differences
you
never sign your signature exactly the
same way
uh two times there's always going to be
slight little differences but the
counties are looking for
those indicators of differences
and if there's multiple of those and
significant then the
signature will be rejected wayne thorley
is the deputy secretary of state for
elections is that enough
to prevent voter fraud it is and it's
also no different than
identification that is done at the
polling place
signature verification is not unique to
voting by mail
if we were doing exclusively in-person
voting we would be verifying voters
identities
by signature also when a person goes to
the polling place
they are asked to sign the roster also
called a poll book
and then that signature they put on the
poll book or the roster
is compared to the signature that the
county has on file for the voter
during the primary more than 12 thousand
ballots were initially rejected about
two and a half percent of the total
number of votes according to the
secretary of state's office
nearly 7 000 were not counted because
they couldn't be resolved
gloria says the machines in clark county
are programmed
the same way they were for the primary
how can you explain
what the margin of error is that's
difficult to do
if it meets the requirement that there's
an algorithm in place that the system
uses for the first check
after that there's forensic training
that my staff goes through that they
pass on to the
election staff that goes through and
verifies those signatures thorley says
the secretary of state's office does not
check
voting machines in clark county because
there's no law requiring that oversight
he also says secretary of state barbara
sagavski has been an
advocate for a voter id requirement
which
does not exist in nevada vanessa murphy
8 news now now we have information on
how you can register to vote and a lot
more about the election at 8newsnow.com
meanwhile the presidential campaign
wound its way through las vegas this
week on monday ivanka trump president
trump's daughter
she stopped at legends ranch near
windmill and las vegas boulevard
campaigning for her father
she spoke with former white house press
secretary hogan gidley about
manufacturing jobs in the country
former secretary of state and one-time
democratic presidential candidate john
kerry campaigned as you see here
on behalf of joe biden in las vegas he
told the i-team's david charns
biden administration would support
recent peace deals between israel and
other middle eastern countries
would the bodine administration continue
to uphold those deals and is this
something that
uh you know joe biden um in kamala
harris support
absolutely joe biden and kamala both
welcomed
the initiative of the united arab
emirates the uae
they took the initiative they're the
ones who live in the region they're the
ones who get the flack if there is flack
and they had the courage to stand up and
do and to
actually sort of cement what had already
been a changing relationship with the
state of israel
but joe biden is is a very very pro is a
long record of support for israel
and of course other candidates and other
members of the different campaigns were
in las vegas as well donald trump jr was
in las vegas on wednesday night
in the northeastern part of the valley
at an engineering firm called civil
works
trump jr told 8 news now the ways his
father's
covet diagnosis has influenced his
opinion on the virus
anyone who goes around him has to be
tested on a daily basis literally
uh and he was still able to get it but
he was also you know he's a 74 year old
guy that probably eats a little too much
mcdonald's and
he walked out in two days so i think you
can take it seriously you can take
reasonable precautions
about 150 people attended that event and
it included speeches from other
prominent nevada gop
leaders including state party chair
michael mcdonald
we put the full interviews with john
kerry donald trump jr and others on our
website
just look for the 2020 election
interviews tab at 8newsnow.com and you
can watch
all of the interviews from other
candidates as well
senate confirmation hearings for supreme
court nominee judge amy coney barrett
wrapped up on thursday in washington
on capitol hill judge barrett declined
to answer many questions from democratic
senators
she said she didn't want to prejudge an
issue that might come up in a case
meanwhile republicans spent the hearings
defending her
i would be afraid to ask her about the
presence of gravity on earth
she may decline to answer because it may
come up in a case
certainly there is nothing about this
nominee
that can be left
as suggesting that she's anything other
than an extraordinarily gifted jurist
democrats claim they haven't had
adequate time to review
judge barrett's nomination the question
is
well what stood out let's ask our
washington dc correspondent alexander
limon with a look at
what we've learned from the hearings
during the week and what came up that
could derail the nomination moving
forward alex
hey there well i would say that one of
the things that really stood out is how
different these confirmation
hearings were compared to brett
kavanaugh's confirmation hearings
you know they were a lot more civil and
cordial the interactions between the
senators
and the nominee and also a lot more
informative we did learn
a little bit about her her family her
past her time
on the seventh court of appeals and also
about her faith that was something that
came up a lot she is
a catholic and she is pro-life but the
argument that republican
senators tried to mount here is that she
can and has in her past
separate her personal religion and her
views
from her rulings on the court that she
takes her job very seriously
and that she will be able to do that on
the other hand democrats
say they highly doubt that they have
their doubts in part because president
trump has tweeted
a lot that he expects his nominees to
the supreme court to
quote unquote do the right thing and
kind of things like that which
they say that makes them worry and
skeptical well you alluded to some of
the
supreme court cases on the horizon we've
got the vote now scheduled for next week
let's talk about the timeline and why
specifically for republicans they want
to get her confirmed
before a lot of these things on the
horizon come to
present day so the senate judiciary
committee is going to be voting
on october 22nd to advance barrett's
nomination to the full senate
so that's a thursday and senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell said that the
full senate will begin
debate on her nomination the very next
day that's a friday so we do expect that
debate
to carry over into the following week
but also we expect that
you know that last full week of october
that that's when the full senate
will vote a final vote on barrett's
confirmation to the supreme court we do
expect that she will be confirmed
because republicans do have enough votes
to accomplish that
and that as alexander was alexander
limon from washington d.c
next on politics now making their case
for congress
and when you look at the voting record
for susie lee
you see that she voted 99 with with uh
nancy pelosi and 95 percent with aoc
dan rodimer tells us why he says he's
going to put nevada first
and the integrity of the election here
in the silver state we're also going to
hear from his opponent susie lee the
incumbent
on her top priority and a few surprise
endorsements
and i'm asking for your vote welcome
back
to politics now
the race in congressional district three
it has had the most money spent
and it's the most contentious it
features incumbent democrat suzy lee
versus republican challenger dan rodimer
according to open secrets lee has spent
more than 788 thousand dollars for her
re-election
rodimer has spent 685 thousand dollars
millions more has been spent by outside
groups now there is no candidate debate
in this race
the i-team's vanessa murphy interviewed
both candidates this week to help you
make an informed decision
here's her discussion with dan rodimer
can you name
three specific bills you would try to
pass
there's certain things that we need to
work on you know
right now and it's really pathetic
because you hear republicans
you know there's some republicans that
are you know uh on certain topics that i
get frustrated with
democrats you know i mean like social
security
they're like you know everybody's giving
up on it
i think there's no way i will ever ever
ever ever vote on a bill that will
defund or
uh or take away social security from our
seniors you know healthcare
you know right now you know i don't
believe in socialized medicine
i just don't you know susan he does i do
not i believe that
we should have you know competitive uh
health care
and you know i told everybody
you know i will never take anybody off
the current health care system i'll make
sure everybody has
good health care but or have health care
but you know i won't i will never vote
on anything where
you know they won't allow you to come on
with a pre-existing condition we need to
protect
these people and a lot of republicans
you know they don't have a backbone to
say
we're going to protect pre-existing
conditions
you know i'm very very passionate about
a few things er
you know social security you know health
care
jobs in school school's another one i am
a huge advocate for school choice suzy
lee did not
agree to a debate what do you want to
say about that
well i think the people here in nevada
have the right
to hear from both sides i think they
should
um you know the fact is you know
my background yes i was a former wwe pro
wrestler
i was probably the worst wrestler in the
wwe but i was very good on the
microphone
and in law school when i went to law
school i was the best student i was a b
student but i was very good at debating
you know these are the attributes that i
will bring
to congress you know in addition to
being a small business owner
here in nevada we own restaurants here
and
you know it's very very frustrating that
folks can't hear both sides
and right now all you're seeing is susie
lee is attacking me she's attacking my
family
on tv non-stop we've heard president
trump
uh question the integrity of this
election will you accept the election
results in nevada
look people come to me all the time and
they're worried about
fraud and they're worried about you know
um
ballot harf is saying you know it's it's
illegal here i mean it is legal
you know people republicans argue about
it all the time well it's all right
but you know if that's the law of the
land
you can do it then you know you're gonna
see folks out there doing it
um now do i think you know
if we find out that other people are
filling them out
and people are signing other people's
names and
they have proof of it and yes i would
expect
you know if it was either side i'd
expect suzy lee to do it or or
you know dan roadhammer to do it
but um i hope that there will not be
you know any any fraud um and i
encourage everybody if you want your
ballot to count
you should probably go in person and
vote in person either early voting or
even absentee despite cobit 19
if you feel safe to go out
and vote in person early i would
recommend it
as rhodeimer mentioned he is a former
professional wrestler
he and his wife now own a vegan taco
shop here in town they have six kids
including one that was born less than a
month ago coming up next here on
politics now susie lee
lists her priorities as i've said before
i am a one
issue congresswoman at this point we'll
tell you what she says
is her number one priority in congress
solar satellite provider
you're watching politics now
we are back with more on the race in
congressional district three
democrat incumbent suzie lee is taking
on republican challenger dan rodimer
and she spoke with the i-team's vanessa
murphy
and my first question is about some
endorsements maybe unexpected like the
review journal
uh chamber of commerce usually going
republican but they endorsed you what do
you want to say about that
well listen i am proud to have those
endorsements and i think it's a
reflection of the work that i've done in
congress
since i've been there for two years of
really trying to work
uh with both parties across the aisle in
a bipartisan manner
to get things done that are so important
to nevada families and
i think there's a recognition that i'm
putting politics aside and trying to get
progress
and solve problems as you know i joined
the problem solvers caucus which is a
caucus of 25 democrats
and 25 republicans when i first came to
congress
and really that was my commitment to the
constituents of congressional district 3
that they actually want to see a member
of congress who's going to
try to outreach and build relationships
uh with members of both parties joe
biden finally
said he is not a fan of court
hacking what are your thoughts
listen i you know my thoughts are right
now we are
faced with the most major
crisis at least in my lifetime in this
country this pandemic
families are on the brink of collapse
businesses are on the brink of
bankruptcy
and uh this administration is choosing
to rush through supreme court hearings
at this point um looking at basically
being able to place a justice on the
court just in time
for the supreme court hearing on the
affordable care act
which would take away protections for
pre-existing conditions from millions of
americans
so i find it that right now
as i've said before i am a one issue
congresswoman at this point i think the
biggest issue facing congress right now
is making sure we get another package
past the finish line
onto the president's desk and signed
uh moving on to dan rodimer
um one of his attack ads
claims that you are nancy pelosi's
puppet what do you want to say about
that
uh dan rhodeimer is taking a book out of
the republican party playbook
and basically i think that my
endorsements speak for themselves the
review journal
the chamber of commerce i've been ranked
by the lugar center which ranks
members based on their bipartisanship as
one of the most
bipartisan members of congress and so
i think it's a false attack but it's
basically one that is being played all
across this country
uh by my on you know by republicans who
are
uh going after seats held by democrats
and
um you know but then you have to look at
what
rhodeimer's uh what rhodeimer's
record is and basically he's running on
a record
of basically being pro-trump and he's
holding on to those coattails and so i
think it's an interesting attack
you can watch more of the interview with
susie lee the congresswoman and dan
rodimer
her challenger at 8newsnow.com look for
the 2020 election interviews tab
and while you're there check out
interviews with other candidates running
for office as well
las vegas sands review journal owner and
gop mega donor sheldon adelson making a
late in the game splash in the
presidential race
political reports adelson gave 75
million dollars to the anti-joe biden
super pac preserve
america that was about 90 percent of the
group's fundraising back in september
the center for responsive politics says
preserve america is now one of the
largest outside spenders in politics
that's after the pro-biden super pac
priorities usa
and america first which supports
president trump
president trump back in nevada tomorrow
we're going to tell you about his rally
up in elko coming up on
and nevada families lose
[Music]
and finally here on politics now here's
what we're keeping an eye on in what to
watch president donald trump holding a
rally in northern nevada on sunday this
is his video
from the last rally he had in rural
nevada september 12th in minden
thousands of people were attending there
sunday's rally is scheduled to be in
elko but it has since been moved to
carson
city so we're going to watch to see what
the crowd size is up there and whether
it fits into nevada's kovid 19 rules
we're also keeping an eye on early
voting and mail-in balloting
so far democrats have voted at a pace
three times that of nevada republicans
so we're watching to see if that keeps
pace or if republicans can
close the gap don't forget early voting
is now underway
in nevada and if you go online to
8newsnow.com you can find out all the
information you need to know
about voting registering and taking part
in the upcoming general election
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you very much for watching
don't forget you can keep tabs on all
the political news on eightnewsnow.com
and watch us every saturday
thank you very much